this week as we continue to focus on the
best new books the man who seems to have
taken the mantle from jk rowling and
harry potter as the voice of the next
generation of readers
jeff kinney's diary of a wimpy kid books
have sold a stunning 250 million copies
and generated four movies he is
currently out with his 15th wimpy kid
book along with a slew of offshoots
we met kenny on his latest tour a
socially distanced one
though no less fun hi guys
thanks for coming out try finding
another author who will hand you a book
with a pool skimmer i'm going over the
top
or chuck a water balloon at your car
hello sir hi how are you doing
with your kids inside here we go he's
going for it
literally those are my kids well done
such is the life
and touring schedule of jeff kinney the
most popular children's author in the
world
why did you do this i think that kids
really need something fun
right now i think kids need to have
something physical something to look
forward to
something that's not cancelled the deep
end virtual pool party
based off his most recent book continues
jeff kinney's commitment to not just
writing prolifically
hello but engaging with fans nonstop
even at their homes
in august i went out on the road and it
was just me a van
a mask and a six six-foot trident and
that's how we handed off books
and i was really surprised by how
happy parents were to have something to
do to give their kids something that you
know doesn't stink about 20 20.
kenny long dreamed of writing comics but
wasn't able to publish the first wimpy
kid book until 2007
eight years after he began writing down
a diary of the rough
middle school experiences of a fictional
character named
greg hefley i think i'm stuck in this
middle school world just like greg
heffley is
greg is right at the edge of
adulthood you know he's he's still a boy
he's not really becoming a man yet
and i like the situations that those
kinds of kids find themselves into
i like things that are right at the edge
of childhood's end
have a great day sweetie pie
kenny's first book quickly became a
smash hit
and almost immediately movie studios
were calling i was really scared when i
was first approached about a movie
because
my second book hadn't yet come out it
felt like
too soon i hadn't gotten my feet
underneath me and when you start getting
those calls you have to make a decision
really
quickly you're under the gun i'm used to
being in control as an author
and a movie experience is really
different the live action diary of a
wimpy kid movie was followed by
three more the deep end is kinney's 15th
book in the wimpy kids series
all of them mega bestsellers he produces
at least two a year
doing both the writing and illustrating
he writes the jokes first
then constructs the story around it the
pages are full of bathroom humor
inept adults and confused striving kids
sort of normal life or as normal as life
gets these days
kids are really good at rolling with
things but i do think when we look back
years from now
this is going to be a moment that
they're really going to remember
yeah i'm worried about the imprint that
this is going to make on
kids lives you know when we watch films
right now
you see two actors get close together
without masks and you say
you know it's crazy yeah and what's that
going to do to kids you know who
are going to live through a year and a
half of this where
they're being conditioned not to go near
people not to interact with people not
to go into crowds
so i'm worried about it i'm worried
about kids mental health okay here goes
here comes a triple
i'm really just trying to give kids a
laugh you know
i feel really privileged i have an
audience
and i think laughter is needed now more
than ever
in addition to the books and movies
kenny has used his now vast
fortune to open an independent bookstore
in his adopted hometown of plainville
massachusetts
it's called an unlikely story i think
we're living through a time
right now that's quite difficult for
independent bookstores i know that some
won't survive
but i think the importance of
independent bookstores has become
abundantly clear
and i hope that when we enter into our
new world we treasure
things like independent bookstores that
we need to treasure
13 years after his first book the deep
end
is another best seller for kenny no
surprise for his readers
who see themselves in the pages of his
you came up with the stories oh he's a
lot like me you know he's a lot like i
was as a kid
the book for those kids is a mirror and
sometimes that
that moment is really special when when
we meet each other
and see eye to eye of course now our
faces are covered with masks and
there there are a lot more barriers um
so i'm looking forward to a day when we
can connect again more personally
[Music]
do you ever see yourself getting tired
of this all right i hope not
i'd like to get to at least 20 books um
i'm in a real position of privilege
where if i write something
whether it's good or bad it's going to
reach millions of kids around the world
and it's really hard to walk away from
from that
jack fell in love with these books a few
years ago and has read every one
including the latest and then i got to
take him to the the virtual pool party
where they throw the water balloon
at the car which is just a ton of fun
and it's just it's a great gateway for
kids to get into
even more reading um best dad ever i
mean
it might be jeff kinney more books
coming he gets there
to reach a young audience wonderful
stuff from him